if I gave one piece of advice to the
world about how to avoid diseases i
would say have clear lines of definition
and demarcation and that makes it sound
like I'm recommending exercise as number
one because i want the absence of fat
under the skin i think that is the
single most powerful generator of most
diseases it affects cholesterol it
affects triglycerides that affects
diabetes therefore dialysis there for
blindness therefore amputations it
affects cancers and so on so the best
way to do that is of course to put diet
and exercise together as far as
immunizations frankly that's a question
in our culture that is mostly immunized
those people who choose not to get
immunized are sort of living off the
benefits of those who did because the
disease incidence is low but there have
been several studies to show that
whooping cough epidemics have begun to
occur in those populations who have not
been immunized or adequately immunize or
recently enough been immunized and
whooping cough is nothing to fool around
with frankly my children are grown and I
don't know what I would do if the
question were asked me now do you want
your kids immunized for all of the
things they're doing I will say this i
would spread it out a little bit i don't
think you need to jump in in the first
week or month and start the immunization
process as forbes seat belts and you
know avoiding too much sun and hence
melanoma you should be in the sun
vitamin D levels are very low in our
culture you should be in the Sun before
eleven o'clock or after 130 and you need
a great deal you need a high vitamin d
lo you should not avoid the Sun you
should be in the Sun what's happened if
you've already developed a
skin cancer of some variety then you
really need to think about taking
vitamin D as a supplementation in our
Western culture I think virtually
everybody should probably be on vitamin
D I've never seen one person who had a
25 hydroxy vitamin d3 level of 80 which
is considered more or less the best
level everybody in my practice of
thousands of patients is below that
number so I think just across the board
people need vitamin D I've seen a few
people in the 70s but not many everybody
has a genetic predisposition to develop
multiple disorders but those disorders
occur if and only if the person does
what's necessary to express that
weakness so those people who are
exercising adequate virtually everyone
who follows an organic unprocessed whole
foods diet at the eighty seven point
five percent level and who exercises an
hour a day is going to have the kind of
physique that I've just recommended of
course that's a lot of time and people
say who has the time pay me now or pay
me later do what you're supposed to and
then you'll find out that you'll avoid
diseases doctor visits hi co-pays hi
health insurance being rated by your
insurance having surgery and so on and
so on so if you put the time in now it's
like sort of like an education you put
the time and now you get the benefit
down the road
men over 40 should get a rectal
examination for cancer the prostate I
think thermography is a better way for
women to go than mammograms it's a heat
registering technique that gives no
radiation there is a time and a place
for a mammogram there's a time and a
place for an MRI and of course now the
big hot news about cat-scans and so on
is that they are cancer generating at
about one in five hundred so people over
the age of 50 should get a colonoscopy
people should be doing stool blood for
globin GL OB I N or what's called occult
blood to detect cancers of the bow if
you have stomach distress and
intolerance you might need to be checked
for a bug in your stomach called h
pylori or wheat allergy called celiac
disease so these are some of the kinds
of things but everybody should get their
cholesterol checked everybody should get
their diabetes checked their 25 Hydra
diabetes tests called an a1c they should
get cholesterol which should be less
than 150 triglycerides which should be
less than a hundred a1c which should be
less than 5.5 25 hydroxy d3 which should
be right around 80 and those are some of
the biochemical tests that might be of
interest for people but we've mentioned
colonoscopy mammogram rectal examination
PAP and pelvic for women I do think that
as much as I have hesitancy about the
injection of foreign proteins called
immunizations if I had a daughter I
probably would want her immunized for
HPV but again I wouldn't rush into it
but once she became sexually active I
would certainly want to have a
discussion until she made a final
decision whether or not it should be my
decision at this point she doesn't have
a voice in that is a different
discussions
disease reversal is not impossible you
can reduce the weight of diabetics and
for all apparent reasons hi there
diabetes goes away you can do the same
for high blood pressure you can for lack
of a better word put it in quotes cure
there are doctors who argue against it
saying that you cannot cure hypertension
you cannot cure diabetes you cannot cure
high cholesterol well it's very academic
whether you want to argue about can you
cure it or not I can make all the signs
of it go away reduce a person to claude
clear lines of definition demarcation
most diabetes will go away the vast
majority of hypertension will go away
then of course you have to address salt
salt intake has to be comparatively low
and you have to address exercise so I
believe that for the most part diabetes
can be reversed almost ninety percent of
high cholesterol can be reversed
virtually ninety-five percent of high
triglycerides can be reversed
cholesterol blood pressure diabetes
cigarette smoking it's been shown time
and time again if you stop smoking the
cells in your lungs begin to change back
to what they should have been and so on
plus you'll reduce when you do all these
things you reduce back pain you reduce
depression you reduce predisposition to
accident overweight people have more
accidents